доброго дня українці клинці україна
україна понад усе
ми ж бідні msi і не від влади води
залежить і
я як частка криму, а нас і
про пошукове і викликав і мокрим тут багата
і багата тих хто збентежений бос виїхати
з криму і геть і наш шкірний
такі заходи приходять там ще чекають
борються razon
і чекан тиця сколи місій з україною
razon але й дим від криму до українського
крима і це будеш витком і так як
нам кажуть що це дуже складний шлях так
c складані шлях алли українці всьому
світла
показав його руку показав ще це таке
коли ти борешся за свою свободу за свою
боньк овчину за свою землю і ми криємо
викликав йому і такі я готовий і ще мразей
акі
за раз не поважає ця до чоловіка і масть
щоб їх але у повернуті назад зараз та
колою був і приянки
ванни теж розчулюються
терпіння c culotte 14 го року за раз ми
все знаємо ще рубає і будемо робити і
всередині зайвого
рів кеш води зміщені і дивитимуся
свої місця таку смола в Україні